todo
[Música]
hola hoy en science click el modelo
estándar
en el modelo estándar reúne en una misma
teoría todas las partículas elementales
que conforman el universo
estas son piezas fundamentales que
constituyen la esencia del universo
entero son las partículas más pequeñas
no se pueden romper ni dividir el modelo
estándar clasifica dichas partículas
elementales en diferentes grupos
para empezar el universo está compuesto
de materia la materia es fundamental
para los seres vivos los planetas las
estrellas y todo aquello que tenga más
las partículas elementales que componen
la materia se denominan fermiones
hay dos grandes categorías de fermiones
los quarks y los leptones
estos que constituyen toda la materia
existen bajo tres formas diferentes que
llamamos generaciones cada generación
está formada por un par de quarks y un
par de leptones
la primera generación está formada por
quarks top y down junto con dos tipos de
leptones los electrones y los neutrinos
electrónicos
estas son las partículas más comunes que
se encuentran en nuestro universo cuando
se combinan en grupos de tres los quarks
of dawn forman los protones y los
neutrones que son los integrantes
fundamentales del núcleo atómico los
electrones también se encuentran en los
átomos orbitando en torno a los protones
y neutrones su carga negativa compensa
la carga positiva de los protones de
modo que la materia permanezca neutra
al circular por cables eléctricos los
electrones también producen la
electricidad
por último los neutrinos electrónicos
son las partículas materiales más
abundantes en el universo más de mil
millones atraviesan nuestro cuerpo cada
segundo tienen la propiedad de no
interactuar con la materia lo que los
vuelve muy difíciles de detectar
la segunda generación de la materia está
formada por quarks carme y strange punto
comunes y neutrinos muónicos estas
cuatro partículas tienen una masa mayor
que las de la primera generación
la tercera generación está conformada
por los quarks stop y boro junto con los
leptones tau y neutrino tauónico estas
cuatro partículas son aún más masivas
que las de las dos primeras generaciones
las partículas de la segunda y tercera
generación son muy escasas en el
universo ya que éste está formado casi
en su totalidad por partículas de la
primera generación
ahora bien todas estas partículas
existen en una de dos variedades en
realidad hay otro tipo de materia que
llamamos antimateria y la cual asocia a
cada partícula una antipartícula las
antipartículas tienen las mismas
características que las partículas
usuales pero su carga eléctrica es
opuesta
finalmente hay partículas que no
constituyen la materia a las que
llamamos bosones un bosón es una
partícula que actúa como mensajera para
permitir la interacción a distancia
entre dos partículas de materia
cuatro de ellos se conocen como botones
de gauge cada uno de estos botones
corresponde a una fuerza del universo el
fotón es el bosón de gauge asociado a la
interacción electromagnética
se desplaza a la velocidad de la luz y
da lugar al magnetismo así como la luz
misma
el grupo es el bosón de gauge asociado a
la interacción nuclear fuerte esta
fuerza se manifiesta a escala
microscópica y es muy intensa
mantiene juntos a los cuartes que a su
vez forman protones y neutrones
por último los botones z 0 w + y doble o
menos son los botones de cauce asociados
a la interacción nuclear débil esta
fuerza subyace a ciertos fenómenos como
la radioactividad de las partículas o la
fusión nuclear que tiene lugar en
estrellas como el sol
en el modelo estándar existe un último
botón el bosón de higgs
el bosón de higgs nos sustenta realmente
una fuerza pero sin campo este campo de
higgs confiere una masa las partículas
que lo atraviesan
cuantas más partículas interactúen con
este campo mayor será su masa
[Música]
en el universo existe una gran
diversidad de partículas elementales que
el modelo estándar reúne en una sola
teoría sin embargo dicha teoría no
permite explicarlo todo por ejemplo el
modelo estándar aún no abarca la
gravedad que es esencial para el
universo
por ello los físicos han sugerido la
existencia de un bosón mensajero de la
interacción gravitacional el gravitón
sin embargo su existencia continúa
siendo sólo una hipótesis
[Música]